ouais mais bokassa on est épargné avec
the do j'ai été parmi les premiers
comics a vraiment joué avec avec vos
origines en entendant 9,45 les [ __ ]
gilles bouleau ça c'est violent
il ya un sketch dans la cassette évier
semoun consacré aux pompes funèbres
exact c'est un incinérateur et vous
dites c'est de la bonne machine c'est de
la marque allemande un calmant devez
vous allez enlever ça dans le spectacle
je n'ai pas enlevé mais c'est vrai que
de temps en temps j'ai été obligé
d'aller m'expliquer auprès de la
communauté juive pour dire que déjà que
j'étais juif tué ce qui s'appelait des
et que bon c'était pour moi une façon de
dénoncer une certaine période quoi mais
c'était pas la peine de prendre ça au
premier degré il ya des gens qui a été
choqué ce que je comprends à mon but
c'est pas d'être de faire du mal aux
gens non mais vous avez quand même
déclaré nouri 0 794 ça c'est violent
quand même il n'y a pas assez de gens
d'obédience judaïque à la télévision une
seule semaine
nous ne sommes pas assez représentées
c'est de l'humour parce qu'en vrai
qu'aujourd'hui avec les juifs qui plonge
avec les des juifs bas j'aurais tendance
à dire oui mais
c'est aussi s'est-elle d'huracan à
l'envers mais c'est pas vrai j'aurais
tendance à dire oui mais j'ai un goal
dit ça il est dur et le lendemain matin
je vais fêter yom kippour non j'avoue
que je suis un chien mauvais juif je ne
suis juive qu'en dessous de la ceinture
d'accord et quelque chose là n'ont pas
non mais toujours casse toi que ça fait
un truc
ah ouais elle elle veut que je me casse
ouais est ce qu'elle peut venir ici pour
me le dire
est ce que c'est possible parce que
j'aimerais inadmissible qu'on invite des
gens dans des émissions de télévision et
que les personnes soient ce soit obligé
de se casser non mais oh que oui je me
casse mois battant du nom
tout doublon ben moi je veux bien
continuer tous les autres sont d'accord
ok mais chic à bon nombre presque tous
les partis un magnéto de l'un de vos
sketches griffi d'accord très bien comme
à ben moi je me sens vieux
s'enhardissent on s'est bien marré tous
les deux finalement vague refi